hi my name is Koh Kim I'm on the Google
Play business development team covering
games for global and Korea hi my name is
Yoshi I'm also looking for the Google
Play beauty teams I'm on the Japan we
wanted to take some time to share some
pro tips on how you as a game developer
or an app developer can take your app or
game to Korea Japan or really any other
country so let's start about how big
this opportunity is in Asia specifically
in Korea and Japan Oh
so in this subways in the subways you
can see that everyone is glued to their
smartphones and what are they doing on
those phones they're playing games and
it's not just the subway it's while
they're walking down the streets heading
to school heading you know heading the
restaurants meeting up with friends I
mean they are gaming everywhere and what
kind of phones do you think that all
these people are playing their games on
Android especially true in Korea where
everywhere is an Android phone and then
even in Japan and a lot of parts of Asia
as well and so how do you take advantage
to get visibility is that you really got
to pick the right game to export so what
game in your portfolio is really gonna
engage like they use the players that
are in these communities well let's take
a look at some of the most popular games
that are in Korea and Japan right now so
in Korea we have games such as dragon
flight any pong fish eyelid ISA Maru
defense games such as cat war and like
unlike a lot of these things is that you
know you can definitely tell that
there's a different art style in a
different way that players actually
would want to like look at these games
and actually feel like games and what is
it like in Japan and the Japan so there
are the kata model games plus some same
like puzzle functions or like quois
effect so what's an example of a good
localized game so let's take a look at
glues eternity warriors - this is a very
good example of what you can do to fully
look localize your game for that
okay and so this is just this kind of
like a screenshot of the banner graphic
that you can see for both tourney
warriors - in Korea and Japan and notice
that you know they definitely take in
and been very very detailed on the font
that they use also the way that they
that they localize to that audience so
we think this is a very good example of
what a good localized game can be in
Korea in Japan which also means that
localization does that equal translation
actually can we repeat this again look
it's not equal to translation ships so
this hold carry out there at all our
presentation if there's one thing you
should remember it's this this is a big
point so first impressions do count
let's take a look at this game anomaly
Korea by 11 bits Studios actually this
game anomaly Korea is localized in
Korean there is actually a Korean
translations within the game what's
actually very unfortunate is within the
Google Play listing in Korea there's
actually no Korean screenshots or banner
graphics or anything that's translating
which is actually very unfortunate for
the Korean player who actually looked at
this game is like oh look it's like if
this game looks really cool really
awesome graphics but they have no idea
that it's in Korean because all
everything everything in the description
is in English I mean and this thing can
be probably true for you guys in Japan
yeah video you know is there everyone's
hot to lean into English once they are
translated to the Japanese oh they can't
understand that what's a games on right
so that's why you should localize your
listings to your fans in Korean and
Japanese especially if the game is
available in those languages if you look
at gun bros 2 what's great is that they
actually created specific graphics but
for not only an opulent for the English
game but for Korean and Japanese and I
actually think the Korean version of
this graphic is pretty cool-looking I
think the Japanese one is looks pretty
cool pretty cool and this or is it
pretty different their Korean versions
and Japanese versions and then feature
graphic a second version using the coins
entirely the coherence and also the
Japanese version using the original
titles plus Japanese and
not just about what since in the Google
Play Store listing like lip it's all
about what you do within your game as
well so you really got to think like
your local gamer in the sense of that
you have to figure out how your gamer
within Korea and Japan is actually going
to play your game so we have two
examples that are actually very good
examples again we have some Alliance
earth village in Japanese actually and
then we also have madfinger Shadowgun
deadzone that's actually in Korean but
also localized in many other different
languages what's really great is that
they actually thought about how the text
is gonna fit within the context of their
game
so in the case of sort village it's
actually pretty simple you know it's all
it's a social network game so they
really did focus on allowing the user to
be able to manipulate their village and
kind of make the game changes as
necessary whereas in shadow guide you
know it's all about like upgrading your
equipment upgrading your weaponry and
like you know choosing weapons and they
actually made really sure that the
localization was for all of that all
that text was a spot-on and exactly what
a gamer in that region would that take a
sense enough like a machine language
like machine translation language yeah
is like as far as some of my Korean
friends say that was like they didn't
even know it was developed by a European
developer so that's a good sign mm-hmm
let's talk about a funnel layer in the
Asian language you can see their eyes
their Asian language is pretty different
from the English within the game and
then so you can see that layout is it's
pretty using the pretty weird font and
also their layout is pretty blocking in
the agent wonders so the one thing you
do have to keep in mind is that you know
a
languages do present a little bit
differently from what English or some of
the European languages can put into a
game so sometimes you really got to
watch whether your menu button is
actually big enough to fit that in Asian
language so this is definitely you
should take it in mind definitely
something to tell your QA teams to check
on now let's talk about speaking the
language and so what we mean by speak
the lingo is that you know there's some
things that a Korean and Japanese game
player is used to when they encounter
things such as price for example this is
pretty important for the user so you
really got to make sure your price is
that whatever you set for your in-app
purchases or your like you know or your
prices are actually made are actually
the right price for that region so what
do I mean by this so you know typically
in the US do you see a lot of things
that are $0.99 or in Euros 79-year I
sense but in Korea in Japan there is no
such thing as prices that ends at night
they actually end in zeroes and they so
in Korean which isn't ready that's 1000
won in Japanese it's a hundred yen so
what you see what we see most often
that's actually a pretty common mistake
is that we see really weird currency
converted numbers so if you put in 99
sons in the u.s. you're actually gonna
see 1,050 81 which is actually a very
weird number yes and the next important
thing is to provide customer support in
that local language so what's often very
frustrating for any user is that they
cannot understand who like the the
customer service representing can't
understand the language that the user is
completing it yes so this is a example
from like Japan where actually the
replied review is in Japanese and so
don't reply to review in English you
don't want to piss off and finally what
we want to end on is to know your
players game being played behavior what
do I mean by this is that oftentimes I
like to say that in
female casual game player is a lot more
hardcore than an eighteen-year-old
American boy that's playing first-person
shooters and what do we mean by this
it's actually just means that Asian
players really go through content like
no other you really got to think about
updates you got to think about new
content you got to think about events
I'm Yoshi what does what the puzzle and
Dragon do in terms of like a lot of
their content updates they do in the
everyday is they updated a bit so you
know this is we're in the land of super
competitive and everyone wants to really
eat your content but that's a good sign
it just means you're just gonna have to
keep up so thanks for listening to our
presentation today if you have any other
questions I just let us know
Thanks how do you get though